salue ici c'est la première vidéo que
vous voyez de moi je m'appelle fabian
licka je suis mentaliste mais quand vous
pensez au moment ta liste en général
vous pensez aux mots manipulation même
si vous savez pas très bien ce que c'est
un mentaliste manipuler c'est souvent
associé à quelque chose de mal mais ce
qui est mal c'est quand se manipule tous
souvent sans le savoir ils la plupart du
temps n'importe comment
et c'est ça qui fait qu'on est
manipulable à la fin de cette vidéo vous
allez connaître des techniques de
manipulation éthique que vous ne
connaissez pas encore des astuces pour
ne plus être manipulable et même comment
les manipulations fonctionne à
l'intérieur du cerveau alors aujourd'hui
on a compté et je suis suivi par 4 3
millions de personnes surtout les
réseaux sociaux confondus
moi je n'arrive même pas à comprendre ce
que ça veut dire à un chiffre comme ça
je vous en suis très reconnaissant du
coup certaines personnes disent que je
vous ai manipuler pour vous faire croire
que je suis mentaliste et que je me suis
fait connaître comme ça mais manipuler
c'est pas déjà censé être un truc de
mentalist vous avez compris cette vidéo
va être assez dense et vous avez bien
fait de la regarde
on va commencer par quelque chose
d'honnête je viens d'écrire mon
cinquième livre sur la au suspense
manipulation et ce qui est fou c'est que
j'avais pas osé l'écrire avant alors
qu'il avait été question que ce soit mon
premier livre il s'appelle lentilles
guide de la manipulation et il est sorti
aujourd'hui partout en france
pourquoi anti guide vous allez vite
comprendre j'ai aussi rebelle récemment
où la personne j'ai que son pseudo
désole me reprocher de ne pas expliquer
pourquoi je manipulais la france est l
un des montets lundi des voix alors je
me suis dit il est sûrement temps
d'écrire un livre qui donnerait toutes
les techniques essentielles de la
manipulation en posant une vraie
question est ce qu'on peut manipuler de
manière éthique bienveillante
le truc c'est que les livres j'en écris
4 avant sur le cerveau sur le temps sur
le bonheur ils sont issus de mon métier
de mon expérience personnelle de mes
recherches aussi ils sont même présents
et traduit dans 13 pays donc aujourd'hui
j'ai une vraie vie d'auteur en parallèle
de celle d'artistes sur scène et de
vidéastes la question c'est ce que j'ai
vraiment un truc à apporter sur le sujet
de la manipulation du coup j'ai commencé
à regarder les dizaines et les dizaines
de livres que j'ai la dernière sur le
sujet et tous traite de la manipulation
comme de quelque chose de conscient de
mal ou qu'on peut éviter c'est là que je
me suis dit qui manquait une sorte
d'anti guide différents mais
complémentaires de ce qui existe et
surtout qui pourrait vraiment être utile
à n'importe qui dans sa vie personnelle
ou professionnelle d'ailleurs un truc
qui serait pas élitiste mais qui serait
quand même un peu puissant mais pour ça
il fallait reprendre la base pourquoi la
manipulation fonctionne sur le cerveau
et comment ça se fait qu'on soit tous
manipulateur oui j'ai bien dit tous vos
six mois aussi un exemple concret par
exemple qu'on manipule sans faire de
roquettes manipuler sans faire de
roquettes on l'a tous fait souvent
inconsciemment et inconsciemment ce
qu'on recherche dans ce cas là c'est de
garder le pouvoir de petr redevable à
l'autre et de pas paraître faible en
plus de ça quand on fait pas une vraie
requête
on a l'impression que qu'on laisse le
libre arbitre à l'autre et surtout il
peut rien leur reprocher puisque au
final on n'a rien demandé qu'il a par
exemple ça sonne à la porte et que je
dis à loïc est pas loin
ça vient de sonner lui il va se sentir
obligé d'aller ouvrir mais en définitive
je lui ai rien demandé
j'ai juste dit un état de fait ça vient
de sonner c'est tout ça c'est une
requête implicite non formulés et c'est
une forme de manipulation qu'on devrait
supprimer notre quotidien déjà pour être
sûr de laisser le libre arbitre à
l'autre c'est à dire qu'ils puissent
répondre oui ou non et puis en même
temps pour être sûr de bien se faire
comprendre il ya deux moyens de lutter
contre ça déjà qu'on vous fait une
requête implicite vous ne la comprenait
pas comme ça c'est réglé
vous attendez qu'elle soit explique
site pour agir la deuxième chose c'est
que si vous attendez qu'elle soit
explicite au moins vous avez la
possibilité de dire non parce que je
rappelle un truc de base dans la
manipulation si on vous pose une
question à laquelle vous pourrez
répondre par oui ou par non et que on
vous laisse pas la possibilité de dire
non c'est l'iran le prend mal on vous le
reproche alors c'est que c'était un
ordre déguisé donc vous devez aussi
défendre votre nom si vous n'avez pas
envie de faire la chose l'autre manière
de s'en défendre c'est en nous on fait
en fait il faut il faut faire attention
à faire des requêtes bien explicite en
permanence et surtout accueillir le nom
avec bienveillance
on ne se donne pas d ordre entre nous
d'ailleurs il ya quelque chose que je
développe dans un autre chapitre du
livre c'est le oui en fait c'est facile
d'obtenir le oui quelqu'un mais si c'est
un oui faible c'est un oui qui sera pas
tenue par exemple vous lui demandez
quelque chose pour plus tard effet oui
je m'en occuperai c'est un oui mou en
fait y'a pas de confiance et de valeur
apportée à ce weed donc il vaut mieux
avoir un vrai ils l'ont ferme et pouvoir
en discuter
essayez de le transformer en oui
d'ailleurs d'avoir un we move c'est pas
le oui ça veut pas dire qu'on a réussi
en fait à communiquer entre nous parce
que la manipulation et la communication
sont liés on ne peut pas ne pas
communiquer que ce soit par le langage
verbal où tout ce qui est par hasard
balle les ges les interrogations la
manière d'être etc etc mais également on
ne peut pas communiquer sans manipuler
parce que manipuler c'est pas un gros
mot en fait aujourd'hui on lui a mis une
connotation négative une charge négative
de suc mais manipuler c'est un axe il je
manipule je manipule le livre là je
tourne les pages du livre je le
manipuler garenne positif au négatif en
fait donc c'est plus le côté l'
influence négative qui est pose un
problème et ça aussi j'en parle
évidemment dans le livre vous allez voir
tout à l'heure je vous parlais
rapidement du triangle de cartman qui si
vous ne connaissez pas mais une gifle au
mental c'est le truc qu'on devrait tous
connaître très tôt j'ai donc commencé à
écrire le livre en le structurant comme
ça l'adn de la manipulation
donc en fait la manipulation en fait
c'est quoi pour qu'on soit bien d'accord
sur la définition et sur ce que c'est et
comment ça fonctionne
les mécanismes de la manipulation là on
part vraiment dans le fonctionnement de
la manipulation sur le cerveau avec les
biais cognitif entre autres est ce que
la vente est une manipulation pourquoi
le savoir c'est le pouvoir et ses jeux
détail après et ensuite ça se découpe en
deux gros chapitres la manipulation
positive donc la manipulation
bienveillante éthiques
la manipulation honnête
la notion de libre arbitre en fait en
gros la manipulation en fait qu'on
laisse le libre arbitre à la personne la
possibilité donc de dire oui ou non au
ou de faire un vrai choix dont on n'a
pas biaiser les données de départ
et si on n'est pas mensonger si à aucun
moment on ment dans la discussion alors
c'est de la manipulation bienveillante
c'est à dire que les enjeux sont très
clairs la personne c'est ce que vous
voulez obtenir donc ça aussi c'est très
clair il n'y a pas de mensonge
il n'y a pas de tromperie il n'y a pas
de falsifications dans les données et la
personne peuvent prendre vraiment la
décision qu'elle a envie de faire c'est
juste une argumentation scène dans ce
cas après je parle du poids de la
présence naturelle entre autres et après
on passe sur la manipulation négative
la manipulation négative ça va des
techniques courant de manipulation et de
leurs boucliers dans votre vie
quotidienne personnel ou professionnel
jusqu'à la limite des compliments la
manipulation collective les voleurs de
sommeil etc
encore une fois c'est le sommaire
généraliser le sommaire détaillé
beaucoup plus gros comme ça
comme vous pouvez vous en douter et je
vous mets aussi une bibliographie et un
index thématique à la fin on en arrive
au triangle de cartman ça va vous
passionner en gros stefan dartmann qui
était un psychiatre américain pas qu'il
y ait un psychiatre américain d'ailleurs
en 1968 il établit un modèle qu'on
appellera le triangle dramatique qui
permet de visualiser pour la première
fois différemment les relations inter
sociale en gros il ya des gens qui
disent qu'il a découvert notre théorie
de la relativité de la gestion de
conflits le triangle dramatique c'est un
triangle de manipulation qui va mettre
en scène trois typologies personnes la
victime le sauveur et le manipulateur
je vais vous expliquer ce triangle et si
vous faites un peu l'effort vous allez
reconnaître des situations de votre vie
quotidienne des choses que vous avez
vécu mais en plus très facilement alors
vous avez vu c'est un peu comme un
triangle équilatéral chaque rôle et haye
puis distance des deux autres rôles mais
ya pas forcément trois personnes ça peut
se faire avec juste deux personnes avec
trois personnes avec douze personnes est
qu avec 100 personnes est la plus tôt
c'est plutôt des groupes qui prennent
chacun des rôles et ses rôles ne sont
pas figés dans une même conversation on
peut passer de victimes à sauveur un
manipulateur rien fx la seule chose qui
reste fixe c'est que quand on est dans
l'un de ces trois rôles c'est pas bon
pour nous qu'on soit victime
manipulateur ou sauveur on est dans un
triangle de manipulation dont il faut
s'extirper au plus vite parce que il n'y
a pas de fin heureuse à ça la victime
pour exister à la besoin
d'un manipulateur et où d'un sauveur le
sauveur pour exister alors on peut se
dire sauveur attend c'est vachement cool
c'est un bon rôle
non parce que pour exister il a besoin
d'une victime et le manipulateur pour
exister a évidemment besoin également
d'une victime pourquoi c'est de la
manipulation négative regarder si par
exemple je me place un rôle de sauveur
ces cas souvent tendance à être mon cas
et j'ai dû travailler là dessus
quelqu'un va faire quelque chose dans
son coin et sans que cette personne
n'ait rien demandé moi je l'arrivée je
veux dire attends je m'en suis occupé
lâcheté fait si je t'ai fait ça est
inquiète et où donc en fait je lui
envoie le message de tu n'es pas capable
n'y avait pas eu de demandes claires
sauveur c'est pas bon en fait le sauveur
ils aident même s'il n'a pas envie
il est de même s'il en a pas la
compétence et ils aident sans qu'on l'y
ai rien demandé
en vrai la bonne posture c'est attendent
qui est une vraie demande réfléchir si
on a vraiment envie d'aider réfléchir si
on est vraiment compétents pour le faire
ça c'est quelque chose de positif se
placer en sauveur c'est quelque chose de
négatif parce que l'autre est forcément
transformé en victime il le problème
quand on est dans le triangle est
dramatique c'est qu'on a tendance à y
rester si on nous colle le rôle de la
victime on va se mettre à s'en plaindre
hélas si la personne que je viens d être
que ça elles commencent à se plaindre de
moi mais je vais peut-être devenir
simplement le persécuteur parce que moi
je vais je faire reprocher des choses
derrière je veux dire attends je t ai
dtt jamais dans la gratitude ces braves
d'être comme ça tu t'en serai pas toi
sorti tout seul
voilà comment je peux passer de sauveur
à persécuteurs ce qui transformerait
l'autre en victime par exemple donc
c'est pas quelque chose de ça et il faut
s'en sortir alors évidemment il ya
heureusement plein d'évolution qui ont
été faits sur les travaux de cartman
dont le triangle vertueux dont je vous
parle dans le livre le triangle vertueux
c'est comment sortir d'un rôle combien
de détecter sur nous mêmes par exemple
vous parlez de sauveur comment je sors
de sauveur en ayant l'attitude positif
bon ça on va pas détaillé la vidéo
dessus je vous invite à regarder sur
internet taper triangle dramatique de
cartman vous allez trouver plein de
ressources
ou alors vous en saurez plus également
dans le livre mais même si vous comptez
pas prendre le livre vous chercher sur
internet vous trouverez l'info du coup
pourquoi l'avoir mis moi dans le livre
parce que j'ai fait mais apport
personnel dans ma vision personnelle
mais encore une fois si on voulait juste
mieux comprendre le trait en de cartman
n'avez pas à attendre d'avoir le livre
assurez-vous mais le problème de sortir
une vidéo aujourd'hui sur ma chaîne pour
mon nouveau livre parce que c'est normal
que je fasse une vidéo dédiée à la
sortie d'un livre qui m'a pris tant de
mode travail pour vous en parler c'est
de se dire comment on parle de la sortie
d'un livre de manipulation
sans paraître manipulateur j'en sais
fichtrement rien donc en fait le plus
simple c'est est de vous montrer le
sommaire de ce qu'il y avait dedans etc
cinquième livre ça c'est un petit peu
fou et à partir d'aujourd'hui vous le
trouverez dans toutes les librairies
j'ai tous vos libre est habituel préféré
si jamais ils n'ont pas évidemment vous
leur demandez il le commandent ya pas de
problème et si vous préférez les grosses
enseignes ici trouvent aussi les fnac
les leclerc les cultures à ce genre de
choses pareilles s'ils l'ont pas ils
peuvent vous le commandez et si vous
préférez faire de la commande en ligne à
toutes les enseignes habituelles l'ont
alors vous avez un lien dans la
description il vous renvoie vers plein
de trucs verts les librairies
indépendantes ça vous dit toutes les
librairies qu'ils ont un stock vers les
grands classiques
amazon fnac cultura leclerc culture ce
genre de choses également vers ma
boutique à moi brainstorm points comme
là il y aura nombre d'exemplaires
limités ils seront dédicacés je crois
qu'il en reste
je crois qu'il n'en reste plus je crois
qu'il reste plus je crois qu'ils sont
tous partis en pré commande je ne sais
pas pourquoi je vous en parle si vous
voulez jeter un oeil
s'il en reste ce sera marqué mais je
crois que tout est parti en prêt comme
voilà sur les cinq livres que j'écris
c'est sûrement le plus important parce
qu'il est transversal avec tout ce que
j'ai fait dans ma vie avec mon métier de
scène mon métier d'auteur mon métier de
vidéastes avec ma passion pour le
cerveau ma passion pour nantes à
l'isthme tout se recoupe juste là et je
pense j'espère qu'il sera vraiment utile
à tout le monde
du coup si vous voulez pas vous le
procurer pour vous n'hésitez pas à
l'emprunter dans les bibliothèques dans
les médiathèques et je vous dis pas
forcément de l'acheter mais mais
n'hésitez pas à l'empreinte est quelque
part il est toujours à disposition les
lives et finissent toujours dans les
bibliothèques vous faites le vous prêter
par quelqu'un qui la met juste au moins
feuilleter le un petit peu ou feuilletez
le dans un magasin et élise et des trucs
qui vous plaisent vous allez dans une
grande enseigne
je ne cite pas de nom vous le prenez
vous le feuilletez pendant 10-15 minutes
et vous piochez ce qui vous sera utile
voilà n'hésitez pas à faire ça prenez
prenez soin de vous moi c'est vraiment
fou de pouvoir sortir cinq livres c'est
ya pas si longtemps je vous disais whaou
j'ai écrit mon premier livre pour vous
re situer dans le temps j'avais même pas
trente mille abonnés donc c'était même
pas mon nombre d'abonnés qui m'avait
fait signer avec mon éditeur et je suis
toujours chez eux d'ailleurs chez first
ça sort aux éditions first
merci aux éditions first de me faire
confiance de me suivre sur chacun des
projets merci à vous de permettre ça
voilà je l'ait reçue aujourd'hui donc
c'est une vraie motion pour moi de vous
le faire voir on a vraiment travaillé
des couleurs particulières sur ce livre
parce que je voulais pas les gros
clichés de la manipulation parce que
c'est autre chose il ya de l'éthique et
de la bienveillance partout il ya des
choses dont il faut se protéger est tous
assez détaillé dedans j'arrête de parler
prenez soin de vous merci beaucoup à
très bientôt ocha